I think you can actually know the
difference between someone who's had a
true mystical experience and someone
who's had a twisted mystical experience
is that often the person who's had the
twist mystical experience comes back
from that experience and wants to
destroy the world they're like I
experience everything I experience like
the mystical ineffable root of being and
now nothing matters now all of this is
trash like the whole world is just Maya
like the whole world is just illusion
and none of these things mattered all
your religions all your communities all
your things they're all nothing right if
you listen to people sometimes you'll
hear exactly that tone and to me it's
like well I think you're on the wrong
side of the bed because it's like if
there is something ineffable behind
phenomena then it is the source of
phenomena so it should actually fill
phenomena with this kind of unsaid but
not destroyed like anyways I tend to
always keep that in mind when I listen
to people who talk about that
[Music]
this is Jonathan Pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
[Applause]
thank you so much for agreeing to do
this um
we've absolutely appreciate it and it's
it's amazing that the Australian time to
talk with us my pleasure
so um we spoke with one of your
colleagues the other week John vavaki
and um so he expressed that he called
you in a very high regard and
um thinks he said to us your thinking is
delicious
um
so one of the things that I really
appreciate about
brought to say the public discourses
this idea this approach to religion and
mythology is something that is symbolic
and you're in as part of your symbolic
World
um I was wondering why do you think that
that has been so effective as an
approach to religion
well I think one of the issues that
people have dealt with let's say in the
19th 20th century is that because Many
religious groups have tried to defend
their faith based on let's say
scientific methods or accepting
scientific precept presupposition
uh one of the one of the things it did
is that it in some ways made Faith or
religion arbitrary it's like we hear a
bunch of things that you have to believe
you know so you believe in the material
world and all these weird and all these
scientific causalities being the only
type of structure you can describe and
then on top of that you add something
like so God came into the world and then
died on a cross and now you went to
heaven and your and if you believe I
mean what are you talking about this is
absolutely ridiculous thing to say if
you if you just take on this like
materialist type structure but if if you
believe in that the world is actually
that they depended on meaning and
attention and that attention actually
let's say
at least participates in the way the
world reveals itself to us and so it
means then that the mechanisms of
attention which which is something like
stories images the way that we compress
uh facts together into stories are part
of the way or not just part but they are
in some ways the source of how reality
unfolds
um and so then you can start to talk
about narrative and about ritual and
about images and it makes sense to
people because you're coming at it from
a different a different tack you're
coming at it from the question of
meaning which I think that if you talk
to John viveki you've noticed that
meaning is inevitable you can't you
can't avoid relevant the question of
relevance and you can't avoid the
question of of Telos and purposes like
we see things through these through
purposes and through through relevance
uh and so I think that in that frame
then I can I can show how so one of the
problems with this happened with
religious thinkers is is that on the one
hand you had religious thinkers that
said something like you know let's say
in the more uh conservative side you
know the Bible doesn't mean anything
it's just a description of things that
happen so if you try to look for meaning
in it it's almost as if you're
destroying the factuality of it you're
destroying the fact that it happened
because we're scientists we believe the
world is arbitrary we think things
happen arbitrarily there is no pattern
there there are no these deep patterns
don't exist and on the other hand you
had the same on this like let's say the
opposite of it you had uh religious
thinkers that said oh look at all these
patterns none of this must have happened
because all of these look like
mythological stories they all they have
Rhymes and their structure they have
chiasms they have all these structures
in them and so it's like because we
believe the world manifests itself
arbitrarily therefore all this is just a
bunch of people stuff people made up a
bunch of stories people made up and so
what I'm trying to propose is saying no
the world actually manifests itself
through patterns and so there you have
to have a pattern in order to even
perceive the world and so the so the the
things religion deal with are real they
they deal actually with events that
happen but they just don't describe them
the way you would like them too they
they describe them in a way that reveals
their meaning as a way to say that and
so so because of that I feel like I've
been able to kind of bridge a little bit
uh let's say Christian and secular
worlds and I've helped more conservative
Christians to realize and you can't the
attack that they've been taking is is
nonsense and I think I've helped secular
people say oh okay this is what this
stuff is about it's you know and and
also you know all these things help you
understand religious phenomena in
different ways I don't know if that
answers your your question
it's a brilliant answer thank you very
much and I'd invite anyone here to ask
questions maybe if you could type them
in the chat that'd be great
um
yeah just on this song when you talk
about mythology one conversation you and
I have is does it matter that all of it
happened because that was the
conversation didn't happen did not
happen and now because of Donald
Peterson Christian just got a good hold
because of its talk about mythology and
archetypes yeah it didn't matter that it
actually happens
so so I think that how can I say this I
think that all religions are based on
events you know and even when you just
even when the ancient myth describe the
God they're talking about events they're
not talking about events at the same
level that we're talking at right and so
there are different levels of events and
it's very simple like when I describe
the tying of my shoe I'm not it's not
the same level of event that if I say
Rome fell it's like the the category of
Rome fell is a is an extremely high
event in terms of what it implies what
it you know what it and then people
could even you know argue about it
because it's so big so imagine if you
take that even bigger when they describe
the gods I think they're describing
events just very very high events or
almost very abstract events the way
maybe the best way to understand it uh
but for sure let's say one of the things
that happens in time and you see that in
the Bible and you see that in the Old
Testament in the New Testament is that
there's a way in which people realize
that there's a concretization of those
patterns it's like these patterns
actually happen in the world they're not
just high high patterns that actually
the the world that we live in is
actually patterned in those same way so
for sure in terms of Christianity I
think that Christians I think to be a
Christian you have to believe
in the Incarnation and the the death and
resurrection of Christ and that those
are events that happen in the world now
I've said many times they're not
forensic descriptions and they're not
trying to describe the causalities of
what's Happening you know they're not
trying to describe the nature of the
resurrected body of Jesus you don't see
any of that and they actually tried to
obfuscate the capacity to to to to
Simply see the resurrection as some kind
of you know uh let's say forensic event
that you could describe to a police
officer because there's there's actually
moments when the disciples don't
recognize Jesus they they don't know
what they're what they're looking at
they don't know what's going on you know
so there's a sense in which the Bible
itself is saying yes the resurrection
happened but don't try to box it in like
don't try to to to give it a forensic
description
um but I think it's important to
understand that because one of the the
problems of wanting things to be
symbolic or only symbolic or only
mythological or only archetypal is that
then you again have the same issue which
is that you believe that the world
doesn't actually exist in those
archetypes that somehow the world can
exist just neutrally and arbitrarily but
I think what we're discovering more and
more is that you're making your very
perception your very capacity to
perceive the world is imbibed in those
mechanisms so your very capacity to link
events together in order to see unity in
multiplicity of events is necessarily
archetypal so you could say something
like there's nothing that happens which
isn't to some degree archetypal or that
if we don't if we're not able to see the
archetypal aspect of what's happening
it's it's a fault of ours and that
something like the Saints you know the
enlightened ones could see the pattern
in everything right they could notice
that the entire world is a theophany of
these of these primordial patterns so I
think that that's it's important it's
it's an important distinction because I
get a lot of that obviously because I
talk about similar people they want to
stay up in the symbols and they're
interested in seeing the patterns uh but
it's it's how it lands it's really
important I think and that's what makes
a difference in terms of a way to live
and a way to
to embody these patterns it's not just
something we think about right it's not
just something we read in books it's not
just when we interpret movies it's that
if a movie
is it condensed you know very very
compressed story
of someone's love life let's say a love
movie
your your story of your love life will
follow similar patterns right the
difference between a story just that
they compress it's like it's you take
all the Salient facts you distill them
into sale more Salient facts and then
you compress them together so you take
your love story of your life let's say
and then you remove the bits where
you're going to the the bathroom and
where you're you know you're doing
something else and you're working you
like take out all the bits that don't
relate to the to the pattern and then
you just smash them together and that's
why we have that's why when we watch
movies where we we read books like let's
say novels we have Revelations because
it's like I'm connecting all these
things much closer together and then it
can reflect back on me but those
patterns exist in your life that's why
we care about them that's why we that's
why we find them interesting is because
they're reflecting something which
exists in the world
do you think the same thing is true with
something like music
um in the music is a layered sort of set
of patterns and so I think this is
something that Jordan Peterson talks
about quite a lot and really sort of
emphatically there's this idea that
music sort of embodies this harmony that
people should live in
I think so I think so I think that for
music it's harder to talk about
um because music seems to be much more
abstract in terms of the relations
between the the say the the things that
it posits and so the patterns are almost
in some ways they're more they're more
immediate because they're almost pure
they're just basically so you have
experiences of
let's say you have experiences of of
relationships between sounds that's what
you're experiencing so there has to be a
beginning there has to be an end and
then there has to be some kind of
movement you know of course a lot of
contemporary
um contemporary composers have tried to
smash that or break that as much as
possible but even in breaking it they're
calling they're always calling back it's
like I'm breaking this like I'm breaking
this thing that is that will call and
will create tension and opposites and
and longing for resolution of the
pattern and then you can tease someone
with music by not resolving the pattern
and then finally giving your resolution
which is different from the the the the
one you expected so there are there's
all these things you can do to play with
but I think that that's that's exactly
what's going on in music uh so you have
different Joys that you experience in
music some of them are really more like
a roundabout like a like around where
you have one Melody that repeats and
then you know what to expect and you
kind of you it's almost like it can also
become trance-like where you just keep
repeating the same the same Melody over
and over you you find uh also a comfort
let's say lullabies all these things
that that our parents used to sing to us
or church songs or whatever things that
find comfort then you have more let's
say if you you have more complex
pleasure that you can experience in
terms of pattern where there is more
like a novel right it's like I've set
you up and then I think you think I'm
going that way and then I take you this
way and then oh finally I resolve it in
a way that you think you didn't expect
so yeah that that's what I but I'm not
an expert on music but I think that's
definitely true about music too
brilliant I'd love to dive into some of
your thoughts about Contemporary Art and
music but before we do
um Stephen Chan in the in the chat has
asked some of what has been described
reminds me of fractals with nature what
is the relationship between archetypal
patterns and fractals are they two of
the same or is there some
differentiation
I think the best way to understand
Somali patterns is fractals that's for
sure
um if people are interested in that my
brother wrote a book called the language
of creation which goes more into it in
almost like a mathematical way but that
is really the way to understand order
and it what fractals do
in terms of symbolism is that in some
ways you basically have one pattern
which is like one and many like that's
that's the pattern it's like one in many
and and usually it's almost like one and
two so it's like Unity uh opposition and
then resolution of opposition sometimes
it can become more complex but usually
that's just the basic pattern uh and it
can be represented in all kinds of ways
as a mountain as all these different
these different types of patterns but
the idea that it's fractal is very
important which means that
because you can experience the pattern
at every level you can experience Unity
to let's say it this way you can
experience unity and Multiplicity
at let's say let's take a the
relationship between people and groups
and things you can you can experience in
within yourself we have a multiplicity
of thoughts and and passions and and
ideas but you're somehow able to notice
that you're one person and then you can
do that in a group in a family so it's
like there's multiple people in the
family but we recognize Unity within
that family then you can scale that up
into group into groups into churches or
religious groups or
cities Nations et cetera et cetera you
can just keep scaling that up uh Until
you realize it you you know the idea
that for example the United States is
one thing
you know it's like why is it one thing
it's like billions and billions of
things but it's true through that
fractal relationship uh and
you know one of the things that
modernism has done is that if I we do
want to get into modernism is that
modernism has tended to level the the
fractal nature of things it tends to
want to either re either stay in
opposites you know kind of irreducible
opposites
often wants to reduce it into like a
basic opposite where you don't have this
this self-same fractal structure
um
and so because of that it tends to so a
good example would be
you know the way that traditional
societies are usually set up or have
this fractal nature right so a medieval
village has the home with the Hearth and
then those homes in the Hearth exist in
neighborhoods with churches and then all
those neighborhoods with churches exist
in like a bigger city with the cathedral
the cathedral is the highest building
and then and then it it's like the
center for the entire city and then now
that reproduces itself all the way down
and so what modernism tends to do is
that it it like levels it doesn't tend
to want to understand the the fractal
nature and so it'll create things like
suburbs like suburbs and and uh let's
say shopping centers and then there's no
centers and the houses become
de-centered we don't even think about
you know the manner in which the house
the family would come together properly
in a house it's just like living spaces
basically that are just kind of level so
modern modernity tends to do that it
tends to move towards towards absolute
uniformity
and then also idiosyncratic multiplicity
so if you look at most modern movements
you'll notice that they tend to swing
between those two extremes and so you
can have something like let's say in
painting you can have something like
supremacism and expressionism happening
at the same time you know you have these
movements towards abstraction where we
want to reduce you know if you think of
malovich as painting for example you
want to reduce everything to due to its
absolute Essence like color field
painting even all the way into the 70s
or conceptual art and then you have you
know uh absolute breakdown where it's
like everything goes there are no rules
it's just complete idiosyncrasy you know
tape a banana to a wall and that's
considered equal to any form of art
um so so that's that's definitely what I
think happens it I don't know modernism
as much in in music uh so I sadly but I
do see
something about uh for example a tonal
music in the 20th century
that it has that tendency it's like it
doesn't take it into account the fractal
nature of of how we experience music and
so you have this this like imposition of
mathematical structures that are
extremely complex onto a musical system
that doesn't take into account the human
desire for something like a like a
simple round like a simple return or a
simple cycle of of of of coherent
experience and so you and so it's I
don't think that modern music or Modern
Art is um how can I say this that it's
that it's stupid or that it's you know a
lot of people have this idea that it's
just anything goes no it's not true it's
not anything goes it actually tends to
be extremely like almost tyrannical in
position of like systems of thinking
onto the art and then you end up with
with things that people actually or that
very few people can enjoy because it's
so high that it's it's almost impossible
for it to land
um beautiful um
Tyree Roberts who can't beat here today
and has asked
um you've discussed before your view on
contemporary art as an odd fetishization
of the art object removed from any
actual function could you say more about
that one especially whether you think
that contemporary music has arrived at a
similar place as much crossover between
these two worlds and I wonder if music
might have also been removed too far
from having a functional context I'd
love to hear your thoughts on how music
has evolved in their modern era and he
says thank you so much for your work and
best wishes
no I I totally think that the same thing
happened to music that happened to all
the other Arts is that if you think
about the medieval in the medieval world
people struggle to understand this and
they think that it's that it's actually
like a diminishing of art but in the
Medieval World poetry and music would
always serve a function which is why for
example poetry would be panageric if
most poet you in the medieval times
would be panageric would be something
like celebrating something like
celebrating a king celebrating a saint
celebrating Christ and everything and we
tend to think like that's lower but it's
because it's actually because it was
trying to serve a purpose in the world
and music I think would have been the
same that is most music would have been
either uh let's say folk music in terms
of dancing so it has a communal
um a communal function it would have
been composed for certain events for
certain High figures like kings and and
Nobles or whatever to celebrate certain
accomplishments often related to poetry
as well so let's say someone would
compose a ballad to celebrate a great
feat that would have that would have
happened in a in a battle
um and then you you can see of course
that the highest version of that would
be celebrating God and so the highest
forms of Music would be used would be
directed towards the church and directed
towards a celebration of God and and I
think that even as
secular people I think it's probably
possible to kind of understand why that
is it's just saying we want the music to
be integrated into everything else we
don't want it to stand out as a just a
strange like idiosyncratic thing but
rather we wanted to integrate with other
things and therefore it has to
participate in the world and especially
the church the church would have been a
manner in which it participated in in in
society at the highest level celebrating
the highest thing but then also would
have been in in relationship to the to
the to the Poetry in relationship to the
images as well
um in the space let's say in a kind of
Sacred Space so architecture music all
these things would have come together
into into a kind of Celebration so what
we see with the modern music is first of
all
all already
I think already with the Opera we have a
problem which is that
we have a problem because in some ways
we're moving towards like let's say
entertainment now there's nothing wrong
with entertainment I I think
entertainment's fine but I don't think
that that's the highest part function
that music can play but it's sadly that
is pretty much now today with that it
has been relegated to and I think that
already starts at the moment at uh with
a celebration of Opera as being
supposedly the highest art and you see
the same with dance it's like you know
ballet becomes the highest dance well
it's like yeah I don't know wouldn't the
high stands be more integrated like folk
dancing or or or Court dancing would
have been more integrated into the world
than ballet because ballet is just
spectator and so I think that concert
music already brings music into a space
where it's going to
it's going to reach high so it's like
this is the thing when I talk about this
separation
of like absolute let's say a kind of
tyranny and then a kind of idiosyncrasy
so it's going to bring highs and so I
totally agree that Bach and Mozart
you know and maybe Beethoven are reach
highs that liturgical music didn't
uh because it kind of abstracts itself
and it moves away from its its ground
like the way that it's incarnated into
the world but I think already when you
get to Beethoven you're like in deep
you're you're you're seeing the trouble
like right out the door like you're just
seeing the trouble coming uh and I think
that that trouble starts to unravel
rather quickly and so then you end up
with composers that are so obscure in
terms of popular
capacity to listen like if nobody
listens to they burn that doesn't study
art like nobody listens to all these
these these contemporary these modern uh
composers uh and then and then what
happens is the music that becomes
popular becomes more and more let's say
uh trite and more and more almost like
all in the all in the hips right it just
kind of moves down into the hips which
was there in the Middle Ages like it
would you know there was dance dance was
part of it but there was something kind
of holding it together but now he moves
just into the hips and then it's like
basically you know uh whatever
electronic dance music is the is the the
end of that it's like it's just a beat
basically it's just a beat pop music
it's just it's it's like it's just the
same especially now these like new AI
jet they sound like AI gender I think
they've been working using AI for a
while because you have these like Melody
tropes and then you're listening to a
song you're like what the hell like I
just heard that you know and then they
they people kind of they they pull out
certain tropes from each other's songs
and then all this song just end up
sounding exactly the same it's pretty
it's pretty it's very weird
um so I think that that I think that the
the Incarnation music has led both to
its moving towards something completely
obscure and that nobody cares about
except for people that study music and
then
coming all the way down the one that's
the most incarnated in some ways
it was I think Jazz was the most
incarnate because it had it did have
because it stayed with dance I think it
was still the the best the best of what
the the modern world had to offer was
was Jazz uh but even that gets like
it's like yeah I don't know like I I
think I like listening to Miles Davis
but then I don't it's like I just like I
was like what am I listening to they're
like I can handle 10 minutes and then
I'm then I'm done you know
um just coming back to the question of
liturgical music yes also texts where no
compositions have been returned written
yet for the Liturgy
and as new composers are taking it all
in this day and age uh what advice would
you give to them to write for liturgy
yeah it's rough because I'm not like I
don't know I don't think I know enough
about about music
um
I think one let's say hmm
foreign
I would say one of the one of the tropes
that I see happening you know because in
the Orthodox church right now there is a
kind of renewal or desire to renew and
I'm from the I'm from the Orthodox
tradition so there is a there are some
music musicians uh composers even in the
United States benediction who actually
was nominated for two Grammys his
release his recent Vespers composition
uh is an attempt to try to create
something that is both fully liturgical
in in the best sense but then also takes
into account some of the modern some
Modern development let's say puts it to
the service of the Liturgy
um without blowing it up right and so in
some ways offering something also that
is accessible
to people
uh I know big fashion let's say in the
Orthodox church right now is to is that
use Melodies it can be sung by the
congregation because even in in the
Catholic church and in the Orthodox
Church as the modern world kind of
became more and more present what
happened is the music became more and
more difficult and more you know more
professional and so because of that it
also at some point going to church
became a show
um so we have that now too on the other
end which is like the Evangelical
churches that just kind of keep they
just like make up new songs every two
weeks and then nobody knows them and
then they they just like sing these
songs and they're all they're all pretty
much the same anyways in terms of like
their Melody structures and stuff so I
don't I that's I would say look at some
of the people there Vladimir morozan is
one of the people right now that I know
in the Orthodox Church who's who's
working on that
um and then benediction those are the
two in the U.S I think that are at least
the most uh
effective
so I was thinking I haven't fully
fleshed out this question in my head so
I'm sorry if it's going to be confusing
but a common theme
of what your of your sort of criticism
of modernity and also of recent artistic
development where is a sort of disregard
for meaning and for pattern right so no
no well there's both there's actually
like a hyper pattern you could say a
pattern that is so that is so in that is
so abstract that that it almost no one
cares about it because a lot of the
modern yeah and then there's the
opposite then there is also like
anything goes whatever you can do so
both these scenes have seem to happen at
the same time
okay so what I was thinking was
sometimes when let's say a person whose
Outlook of the world may be a Christian
uh that sees
meaning and pattern in the world as
something object objective that exists
and that reveals the truth that is the
independent of me
um a conversation between this person
and a person who is a complete
relativist for example and doesn't
believe in any meaning or any pattern
um usually what I find when I have those
conversation is uh
the person that doesn't believe in any
sort of pattern feels very much
restrained when they when they are sort
of pushed to believe in a pattern but
if they don't they have to disregard for
example human nature because human
nature is a form of a pattern right yeah
they're stuck you know it's yeah
I totally agree I I agree with your with
your sentiment that is that
you can see it like in the modern in the
modern uh world this desire to free
ourselves from the pattern has led to
things that are so abhorrent and absurd
that you know for a good example would
be you know uh let's say deconstructive
deconstructive architecture in the 1980s
and 90s and so you know Architects would
create buildings with like just a
massive hole in the living room it's
like okay you know there actually are
patterns you cannot live in a house that
has like a 10-foot hole in the living
room because it's just not not going to
happen right so so it actually it's like
it's as if some of the modern I think
some of the experimental music in some
ways it actually reveals
the pattern and so it's like you can
make an effort and listen to like uh
it's a minimalist acoustic music and
listen to you know someone
like grading the site of a counter for
an hour like you can do it it's not
impossible to do it but it's like it's
it actually reveals just how difficult
it is to to get there and so
and so we have for example like for
someone who doesn't who doesn't think we
have patterns like we have a certain
frequency of sound that we're able to
hear
it's very simple we have a certain level
of decibel of of volume that we're able
or that we can sustain hearing that
we're able to hear that we can sustain
hearing those are patterns you just
cannot you cannot avoid these patterns
like you could you could destroy
someone's hearing if you don't if you
don't pay attention to these patterns
and so and then there is a certain level
of variation which people find Pleasant
and those are probably
um they're probably derived from the
human voice they're probably derived
from our thousands and thousands
millions of years of hearing human
intonation and hearing the space that
exists in our in our intonations and so
their derivations and probably
concentrations and derivations of the
the the the possible tonalities in the
human voice and so I don't think I don't
think like I don't see how even the most
secular person
could think that that's absurd it's like
the these are just these are just kind
of like natural you know and you could
say something like
you could say something like uh you know
there are certain birds that make
certain sounds and if the the male bird
makes certain sounds to attract the
female
and if they're off they won't get they
won't they won't reproduce themselves
and I think that that's true about music
like I think that there are certain
there's there's a certain like you know
I mean I don't mean I mean yeah of
course there's a musician getting laid
or whatever but that's not what I mean
but I mean is that there's also like
what I mean is that just that if if
certain sounds don't continue let's say
there's a there's a certain perseverance
of of sonority and and distance between
sounds then those will become one-off
experiments and then they'll go away
uh whereas some things will just
continue the things that continue is
because we like them and we care about
them and we want to we want to kind of
uh perpetuate them so so I think that
even like from almost like a darwinian
perspective you can argue for patterns
basically what I think what I get from
that is that we all live whether we
believe in patterns and meaning or not
we all live as if they exist we just
can't escape Escape it so they exist and
we live according to them
um but in this sort of conversation that
I was talking about uh the person that
doesn't believe in them
or or rather the person lives as if they
exist but feels restricted when they
have to accept the truth that comes with
those with those meanings and those
patterns so I wonder if you could talk
about the relationship between or the
the necessity the necessary relationship
between truth and objectivity and these
patterns and these meanings
what's Pride and and I think it's like
if you want to understand all the
like the source of sin you could say
you're right in the world that's what it
is it's saying I don't they're like I I
there are patterns that have authority
over me and I don't care like either you
just can't get away from it right you
can't eat rocks you can't there are a
bunch of things that you cannot do there
are some patterns that have authority
over you and you exist within that that
uh that's the scope of those patterns so
that exists both objectively in the
natural world but it also exists in the
human world like we have we necessarily
have people that are authorities we have
our parents that were that had to guide
us we have different structures of
authority
um and so I think that I think that
there's just a it's just Pride it's like
it's that's why we see that as the root
of sin it's like the idea of
self-causation it's the idea that I can
cause myself
right I can completely contain myself I
can be free from any type of constraint
um and you know there was a moment I
think like there was a moment maybe in
the late 19th and early 20th century
whereas people could credibly believe
that
um I really don't see how anybody can
believe that anymore
because one of the things that happens
too which is hilarious because like in
the early 20th century really I mean I
can have sympathy for them like I have
sympathy for the for the artist in the
early 20th century they're like we've
got this we're going to do this but then
whatever happened between like let's say
1900 and and uh and maybe
1925 maybe I don't know in music but in
art in visual art it's like then that
set up a new way of doing that nobody
has changed it's like experimental music
or experimental art is no different now
than it was in like 1920. it's like the
Dada artist did everything anybody can
do now it's like not explicitly
everything but every idea that any any
contemporary artist has you know
installations or whatever or or breaking
these rules or whatever art that that
doesn't last long that that that uh you
know that it's like all of this was this
all this happened in 1920.
and so what happened is like even the
counter called for like even the people
that wanted to like break all the
patterns which rule over us created like
a kind of weird
anti-pattern that now people just follow
it's like ridiculous and so you know
it's like who's more conforming someone
who goes to church or a punk rocker I'm
not sure which one is more conforming
like they both have uniforms they both
they both you can recognize them you can
you know it's just that one is like a
kind of anti-pattern but it's still a
pattern and so I think that's what
happens it's like that's what happens
with a lot of the with a lot of the
Contemporary uh or the idea of not
wanting a pattern is that what you end
up is you create an anti-pattern
which is still a pattern and you can
recognize it right you can tell it's
like yeah yeah you're just doing it
upside down dude that's all you're doing
because you turn something upside down
doesn't mean that it's I can't still
recognize it and still recognize it
this this sentiment Echoes a lot of um
some of the things we're talking about
with Samuel Andrea who is another guest
on John Gibson's podcast
he was saying to us that as a professor
of um composition and he in his students
work you can't see any sort of
innovation
um something that's necessarily new
compared to what's happened in say the
last 50 or so years of contemporary
classical music and he he says he said
to us that he thinks that the um the
contemporary music world and I wonder if
this is true about the Contemporary Art
world too is in a period of
consolidation rather than Innovation and
just on on top of that is there a way
that we can get back to looking at
something like Beauty as something that
is objective you mentioned there's a
sort of darwinian sense to that pattern
is there something biological that we
can ground Beauty in so that we can get
back to this sort of sense of
consolidating the Arts I think so I
definitely think so and I think that
there are certain
I think that I think now we're in a good
position in terms of beauty because we
have people let's say people like
Christopher Alexander for example or
what we call the New urbanist Movement
you know these are
you know these are credible and so what
they're saying is this fractal
relationship these fractal relationships
are necessary so if you can't make a
building in any way there are actual
there are actual forms that you inhabit
a space so it's like if you inhabit a
certain space you will be prone to do
certain things in that space and you
can't com you can't make a person a
blank slate like if you if you if you
have a dark Crypt like place you know
it's not the same as a grand staircase
going up and into a two-story building
it's like these two things you're not
going to be the same person in one space
or the other and so design now I think
the almost like a it's like almost like
a scientific
approach to design is bringing back the
I think the idea of beauty and it's
breaking down so if you think about
house for example I'm sorry I'm just an
architecture right now in my mind but do
you think of Bauhaus for example in
brutalist architecture you know they
were thinking that they were going to be
practical and and it was all going to be
scientific and everything but it turns
out they're not it turns out the
imposition of like uniformity in the
world actually kills the human Spirit
like it really it really destroys living
in in in Baja's buildings will destroy
you and so right now I think that we're
people are kind of waking up and think
oh no actually these spaces like they
they they relate to something that we
exist in and so I think we're in a good
place honestly in some ways uh I don't
know in terms of music though but for
sure I know that
um
it's going to start I think that the
fact that it starts with architecture
and City Planning is probably inevitable
because that's the space in which we
live and so if we can see the the if we
can see movements like the new urbanist
movement and these kind of these these
uh
rediscovery of neighborhoods rediscovery
of City centers so there are several
projects in the United States like that
of very interesting projects then I
think that we're going to slowly see
other Arts follow
and so in my own world that's a in the
world of Church of iconography what what
I'm seeing is that the top the top
iconographers in America
are actually issued from Contemporary
Art they're actually issue issue from
the academy right they're not just like
improvised mom and pop people making
making icons they're people who studied
in New York studied in the big schools
and then finally decided to move towards
incarnate uh you know let's say art at
the service to this at the service of
the community
um and so I think that
I think that we're in a good position
and people like like John viveki for
example and his idea of relevance and
these questions like these types of of
uh of categories and you think of Ian
mcgilchrist as well and his and his
vision of how the brain works and how
perception works all these thinkers I
think are opening up the possibility of
really saying so it's like beauty is not
a is not one thing beauty is it's like a
it's a pattern right and so there's a
flexibility it's like a poem there's
there's a form but there's also a kind
of improvisation so that's how we that's
what beauty always manifests itself as
it's it's like there's a pattern and
then there's an there's a spice like an
improvisation part to it if we can find
the the right balance between those two
that's when we that's when we that's
when we knock it out that's when we hit
it so
I just wanted to point out in in
something like um the study of um
remember what the name is to study of
animal behavior
um and basically there's this idea of
fixed action patterns which are
something that is sort of naturally
selected for the animals
um you know will inhabit if um how do
you say because of their evolutionary
history so for example like on on
seagulls you have these little red dots
on the beaks that the the the baby
seagull packs to get the food out for
the mother's mouth
um I would expect something like Beauty
as a pattern as you describe it in a
darwinian sense to be something that's
built into our biology is that is that
um no you're right that it would it
would deeply connect to the way that
we're made and so that's why
uh and I think I mean we have plenty of
examples the old world is just full of
examples just go to a medieval village
in Europe just go just go to a very old
city just walk around and then you'll
understand what it is that's going on
there's like a there's a clear pattern
but it also there's also a kind of
whimsiness through the pattern and also
an adaptivity so it's like one of the
things I think humans find beautiful is
the the adaptation of the pattern to a
particular is the best way to understand
it it's like there it's not just a
pattern and so it's like how does the
church fit in that landscape like how do
what's the relationship between the the
between the the city hall and the church
like if you go to London for example and
you stand there and you see the
Parliament and you see the church and
it's like these relationships of build
of things that we know what they are but
how they're how they come together and
how they're related and how how one is
you know how you have this building next
to the river and you have a bridge and
so it's like I think that that's what
that's what's beaut that's what beauty
is it's like these this interrelation of
patterns to their particular
and so so yeah so
that seems to be exactly how
evolutionary I think that's how
evolutionary
selection works too right it's like if
it's if it's properly adapted you know
then it gets selected and then it gets
and it gets it gets moved up and so and
it's not like we it's not like we're
going to reproduce London in another
city but it's rather that we see how
it's properly selected and that that
very those relationships they kind of
inhabit us in a way
um
it's a pleasure to have you with us
um I have sort of a three-pot question
um the sorry to bring us back to
modernism uh my first part of the
question is do you think modernism is
inevitable
um and the second part you sort of
already touched on when you talked about
beauty and you also talked a little bit
more I feel on the criticism and
detriments of modernism but I would like
you to talk all about the what you think
is productive uh about within it and the
third part of the question is what do
you think is coming next if we continue
the way we're headed
yeah
they didn't get me in like apocalyptic
mode here it's not great it's not good
for you
all right so yes I do think modernism is
inevitable I think the best way to
understand
um
it it's always there so the thing that's
the problem is like it's a fractal
pattern so what modernism is has always
been there let's say but as a spice or
as a as an excess or as a as a as a
movement towards something which is a
little too much so that's how I think
that that's kind of how tradition works
so if you so like I and it and there's
been there's Cycles like that so for
example if you listen to 13th century
you know High music in France I mean it
is CR it is wild it is wild it it's like
the mathematical patterns are extremely
complex you know there's like there's
rhythmic they're like different rhythms
and so and when you listen to it you
know it's almost like it's so difficult
to listen to because you have you have
you have like text you have someone
singing Melodies and then other people
singing and there seems to be no
relation but there's like this strange
mathematical relationship between the
different voices and it's like but then
that it's like could so what I mean is
that these things happen and then and at
some point it
it kind of let's say it breaks and then
it feeds into a more a more embodied
world and it's always kind of there
there's there's gonna be a little bit of
that experimentation I always kind of
think of
um you know if you look at uh Church
architecture again like middle-aged
Church architecture so you'd have the
Saints and you'd have you know the
Biblical images and then in the fringes
and the margins then you'd have all the
crazy stuff like you'd have you'd have
like lewd images and you know monsters
and things eating their own tails and
and like just all this kind of there's
kind of experimental space which was
held in the margin and so the same with
manuscripts for example so you had the
main image in the center and then you
had an experimental space in the Border
where you would you could go you could
go wild like do any do all whatever it
is like you know knights fighting snails
or scatological imagery all kinds of of
stuff that is that is usually not
explored in everyday life so I I think
that what modernism did is it basically
took that and just like put it out there
it's like that's what the world is about
now it's about it's kind of about the
extremes
um and so in some ways I do think that
in big Cycles will will come to moments
where these extremes will manifest
themselves
um
so you know we saw that we saw the same
happening in the late Roman Empire for
example you know or like let's say the
the the late Roman Republic and early
Roman like at that transition there was
some really wild things like there were
mosaics that made
um they would make mosaics of crumbs
and so they they would make like a
mosaic where it looked like somewhat had
eaten the day before and had left crumbs
on the table
and like that was their decorative
element
uh and so they would they would have
like images of yeah like decompose
things and there was this this this
experimental space that was opening up
that was becoming really uh really
intense
um and I I think that you could even
argue that ovid's metamorphosis is a
very modern
text you know uh and that's why Augustus
hated it so much she's like it's like he
hated of it he's like just talking about
sex all the time and then talking about
so it's like these moments have happened
before you know so I think so so what is
its use
so one of the things that that it does
is that it does it exposes the pattern
in some ways because you could say that
in a normal traditional world
um things are just natural like people
don't necessarily think about these
these questions they just live them
right it's like animals like animals
don't ask themselves about the patterns
that they that they inhabit but when
things start to go awry and things kind
of start to sh to go into extremes where
you actually see extremely
extremely like difficult uh obtuse
patterns up here and then you kind of
see idiosyncrasy down here you're like
oh wait a minute like you can you can
kind of see what's going on uh and I
think that that scene can then be fed
back into a more embodied world and so
that sounds abstract what I'm saying but
so I I do believe that
I do believe that let's say the future
will be an integration between
embodied
you know kind of Incarnate art with
enough understanding about what
modernism proposed to be able to
integrate it in a way that doesn't call
attention to itself completely and so a
good example if you're interested
there's a there's an iconographer his
name is um father sillywan justiniano I
think he's one of the best icon painters
in America
um he was an abstract post-modern kind
of post-modern abstract painter in the
90s and you know he had all these
Scholarships in New York he was he was
doing great like he was he was on that
on that um path and then he became a
monk
um so he began painting icons and what
he's been doing is integrating let's say
extremely
um sophisticated color field Theory and
let's say the principles that were
developed by the abstract expressionists
into his painting and so the way in
which like in the 70s the theories about
color like that they came up with were
crazy about you know they went really
deep into so they would make these pains
that no one could ever care about right
just a bunch of squares like a bunch of
squares of color but it was the theory
that went behind it was an extremely
sophisticated understanding of color
relationships and vibration and how
colors affect each other and so it's
like you can take that and put it back
into something great you can think the
same about literature it's like the
modern writers if you think of Beckett
or you think of Joyce you know they're
they're they're deep understanding for
example of both
like pattern and abstraction and
and also of idiosyncrasy at the same
time like that kind of relationship that
extreme relationship they're able to to
create can feedback I think into
into the modern world so if you want a
good example of that I don't know if you
know there's there's a author's name is
Paul kingsnorth and and he does that
like he he writes something like Beckett
meets Toki I mean it's crazy he wrote a
novel called Beast it's like it's an
astounding novel but he he actually
grammatically he actually trans he
actually changes the grammar of the
words as he's so his character as he's
losing his mind like the gramat the the
grammar of the the sentences starts to
break down in the story so he uses
modern tropes of actually playing with
grammar and playing with punctuation and
this is like really avant-garde stuff
but he's ultimately telling a story that
follows the
the the the mythological pattern so
um so I think there are ways to do it I
don't know in music I'm afraid I don't
know enough about music that'll be you
guys people point to arvo Parrot a bit
like I know people point to arvo Parrot
as a possible solution to the conundrum
as someone who is integrating you know
avant-garde into a more kind of embodied
and
and uh and celebratory uh music so
oh someone's racing yeah
uh yeah uh
do you believe that uh
the art form or music is uh created or
it's rather discovered so if there is
I've seen it as an objective Beauty uh
that uh
I suppose it's uh derived from natural
uh patterns so that uh we just would you
say that it's a more closely to be like
discovered like as if you were like I
don't know as of um
yeah yeah I know I understand exactly
what you mean
um
and then and then uh yeah
uh then we say the contemporary music uh
because it disregards for
um the
PC and the natural
um patterns is as such more closely to
be creative because it's more of a
random
chance
yeah yeah
um so I would say
I would say to your fur the first part
of your question
I would say that it's both I know that's
boring as an answer it's like I'm not
going to answer but I I think that
anybody I think that anybody who has an
an intuition
um a real intuition feels like they are
not it's not doesn't come from them like
if you like when that happens usually
you're on the right track at least in my
in my case like when I have an intuition
and I feel like that intuition isn't
from me that like you said I feel like
I'm it's like
falling into me or right it's like I
I'm being I'm being assaulted by the
idea you know it's like you it's like it
just seizes you and then I think most of
the time you feel like you're
discovering at least I do
um but then there then there's also the
implementation and I think that in the
implementation then you have more of
this kind of giving birth or this this
forming and the shaping right because
usually what you have
um as an Insight doesn't have body at
least I don't know about you guys I'm
not a musician like I'm talking about my
own experiences so usually what comes to
me is inside doesn't have body it's like
almost like a yeah it almost is like a
like a relationship right a pattern a
relationship and then and then when I
put it into the world then there's a
shaping that comes so I think that that
would be the way that I would at least
uh
I would I would you know um
describe it let's say
you know so an example like I've been
I've been just for a while now I've been
wanting to like rewrite Fairy Tales
um and so and I the way that I want to
do it is I want to get to the fairy tale
like I want so for example like I don't
understand Jack and the Beanstalk I
never understood Jack and the Beanstalk
since I was a kid I was like what is
this story about like why is this the
hero he's he's like he's stealing from
the giant like what why so why why like
what is happening in the story and so
it's like I've basically just been that
question has just been in my mind for 20
years I mean not more you know 35 years
or whatever 40 years
um
and so but recently I'm like no I wanna
I need I need this like I want to write
a version of Jack and the Beanstalk so I
just let that there
and then I don't know how it works I
don't know how it works at some point
you know I'm sitting there I'm like
and all of a sudden it just like it's
like a lightning bolt right just strike
through and you're like oh
I get it I know what that's about like I
don't know what that story is about uh
but then I have to write it like I
haven't written it yet you know
um so in terms of contemporary music
like your second part of your answer I
think it I think then again I think that
this is what I see about contemporary
music is that I see that some
contemporary music is actually hyper
patterned like it's it's not it isn't
idiosyncratic some of it is like I'm
gonna have this pattern and I'm gonna
like I'm gonna shove it down your throat
like I'm gonna just like make you listen
to it you know even though it's
unbearable but it's like here's my idea
I have this idea and it's like this idea
that I'm just gonna like like just force
into the world almost and so I think
there's a lot of that in Contemporary
Art in general and and I think
contemporary music especially and then
then but then there's also the other
exactly what you said there's also the
other part which is just like this kind
of like noise where you know like oh
like yeah I dropped this whatever like I
hit the side of the bowl and it's like
so you have these you have this sense of
like idiosyncratic sound as well so
that's what I see in both and so I I do
I think that
I think there can be an excess of both I
really see the modern world as something
like a move to into excess and if we if
we try to understand it too much as one
side which is moving towards any secrecy
and if we try to understand it too much
it's kind of authoritarian uh patterns
that are imposed then we we miss one
part of it but if we if we see it just
as like a radicalization of the two
sides which is like which one which is
the internet is the internet the most
the freest most chaotic space to ever
existed or is the internet the most
authoritarian space that has ever been
thought of by man
it's like it's just both at the same
time I don't know exactly how that is
but it's just both at the same time
uh so the thing uh like uh
a sin of a contemporary music is that
it's too much of a following that's
right of course too much
fun do you think it is
I think that it's I think I really do
think that it depends on the music I
think that it's it's a so you think
about this think about two sins right
think about one sin and both of them
have to do with pride right
the first sin is saying I don't want to
submit to any rules you know I'm my own
person nobody's gonna tell me what to do
right that's the first sin the other sin
is oh I'm gonna make this happen I don't
care if the whole world resists me like
if all reality resists this thing that I
want to do I'm gonna do it and there's
nothing you can do to stop me it's like
you can see they're both they both come
from the same the same uh Source but one
one manifests itself as an authoritarian
desire to impose a pattern on something
that can't hold it or doesn't want to or
or you know will just get crushed by it
and the other one is refusing all
natural patterns and wanting to move
away so I think that it's just both at
the same time
I just want to ask uh about you as a
Christmas
iconography and an artist I know correct
me if I'm wrong I understand in Orthodox
tradition icons even in the Catholic
tradition icons are seen as a window
into heaven and each uh you know symbol
of the hanoid color is seen as a very
theological expression and any changing
or innovation of that could be even seen
as heresy so how do you as an artist uh
kind of break those boundaries so you
know
express yourself and how do you move
forward with that Earth
yeah so
I think that
some of what you said I think has been
vastly uh like exaggerated in terms of
in terms of just how strict it is and I
think and I and I understand why you
know it's like
I think that I think that some people
who uh felt like most Contemporary Art
which is anything goes and that you know
there was no there were no rule Rhyme or
Reason and no no meaning then look back
at Medieval art and thought wow these
things have pattern these things are
meaning these things have have a sense
and then they just want to hold on to
that but the reality of traditional
iconography is that it is extremely uh
variable there's a lot of variation
variation in Styles variation in in
tropes now it's not an absolute
variation there are there are uh limits
and there are troves there are patterns
that you have to follow in order for it
to be
recognized by the community in which
you're trying that you're trying to
serve and so that's probably the best
way to understand it it's almost like
you could understand it like um you know
English has certain grammatical rules
and if I if I don't use those
grammatical rules then people won't
recognize that it's English and so if I
make an image and I'm like well you know
I want Jesus to have a pumpkin head well
I'm sorry to tell you that no one will
recognize that as Jesus and therefore it
will be seen as heresy and so so it's so
there's a so there is a way in which we
recognize something as belonging to the
tradition uh but you'd be surprised to
what extent there's variation
um and I think that the way that I see
it is that Innovation is neither good
nor bad Innovation is a neutral thing
innovation has to serve a purpose and
when Innovation serves a purpose usually
the strange thing that happens is people
recognize it
people recognize it as being traditional
having been traditional the whole time
they they have us they have the feeling
that that they've seen it before but
they haven't
so it's like I've created images which
absolutely never existed before in the
church but I've never had anybody
complain because let's say the spirit in
which I did it the reason for which I've
done it was was in order to with love
towards the community it's like I don't
want my purpose isn't to like show you
that I'm the like you know call
attention to myself show you that that
I'm better than you that I'm smarter
that I you know I thought of this new
thing that I want to kind of shove into
your face it's like no I want I want to
serve this community I want to
participate uh and so a good example
would be
so for example in the Orthodox should we
have an image of the of the Resurrection
so we have an image of Christ going into
death and saving Adam and Eve right it's
like it's a you see you see Christ like
holding Adam and Eve he's like pulling
them out of death
and so and so then we also have the
image of of the crucifixion of a cross
and so at some point I started making
crosses that had that image on it
and and I had never seen that ever and I
don't think that actually exists but
no one ever said anything it was totally
fine and so priests started wearing
crosses with this image on it and like
no priest in the history of the world
had ever worn a priest with that image
on it but it was totally fine because
it's like I'm not I'm not putting a cat
there but I'm not putting Justin Bieber
I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm doing something
which is like it's like a it's like a
poetic
reformulation of something you already
participate in right it's like it's like
oh wow yeah an image of of of of the
descent into death on the cross like
maybe they don't even think it they just
see it and it's like yeah that makes
sense
so I think there's a lot of that where
it's a lot of the problem that modern
religious artists had is that it doesn't
it acts out of the sense of Genius Like
the sense of of trying to keep up with
the times like it's not acting with the
desire to
to integrate and to make something
participate in the community but if you
do that you'd be surprised at what you
can do you can actually do quite a bit
I think I think it was Isaac Newton who
um always carried a Bible as a nafis is
his arm or something like just like this
idea of like constant serving his genius
to something higher than him Magnus in
the chat asks a mystical question he
says do you experience something under
the symbolic layer something ineffable
numerous and hard to Define but
something which can be experienced in
the body in moments of silence and death
and the transformed
and so I I yes I do I do believe in that
and so I think the best way to
understand that is that is the source of
the actually the symbolic patterns so
you can understand that let's say at the
core
is something like a
that they had transcended transcended
something something which actually
cannot be described something that
cannot be said something that cannot be
expressed and you can access that you
can have access you can have access to
those experiences where you all of a
sudden feel transported into that space
um but then what happens is that when it
expresses itself
so as soon as it expresses itself when
you when you talk about it when you when
it comes back down into your art or when
it comes back down into the world that's
it actually will inhabit this this kind
of symbolic World
um and so yeah so I I I do think so
um and I think that you can actually
I think you can actually uh know the
difference between someone who's had a
true mystical experience and someone
who's had a
somewhere or a
Twisted mystical experience is that
often that when the person who's had the
twistical mystical experiences comes
back from that experience and wants to
destroy the world
like they they're like I experienced
that everything I experienced like the
mystical you know you know ineffable
root of being and now nothing matters
now all of this is trash like the whole
world is just Maya like the whole world
is just illusion and and none of these
none of these things mattered all your
religions all your communities all your
things they're all nothing right so
there is you see it like you can you if
you if you if you listen to people
sometimes you'll hear exactly that tone
and to me it's like well I think you're
on the wrong side of the bed because
like if that if there is something
ineffable behind phenomena then it is
the source of phenomena so it should
actually fill phenomena with this kind
of unsaid
but not destroy it like anyways so that
I I tend to I tend to always keep that
in mind when I listen to people who talk
about that
um I'd love to get your thoughts on um
psychedelics we talked yesterday
um
yesterday we talked with um Carl Rook
who's one of the authors of the um road
to eluses and one of the experts on the
Palestinian Mysteries we were talking to
him about the difference between
um so in terms of old states of
consciousness
sort of mystical experience in this kind
of thing we were saying we were
comparing say playing a musical
instrument to sort of achieve an altered
state of consummate Consciousness
requires a level of skill dedication
discipline practice this kind of thing
but taking a psychedelic is is very easy
and it does something to you which
people come back and say that was a
mystical experience
um do you think that
um there is a fundamental difference
between something like
um how would you say genuine religious
illumination or a mystical experience
and and the kind of experience that
people describe coming back from
psychedelic chances
yes I do think so I think very much so
um
I I do think that it's like for all the
love of the people that I that I mean
that I exchange with today it's like
it's like everybody's talking about
psychedelics it just everybody talks
about it and uh and I feel like I feel
like it's misplaced and I feel like it's
dangerous
um
so
so a good a good example the LCD
ellucinian mystery is actually a good
example of this very problem which is
that
let's say the ellucinian Mysteries had a
psychedelic in their ritual right and so
people tend to think that that's true
and they tend to think they have proof
of that
if the Dallas Indian Mysteries had a
psychedelic
the Ellis cinemistry lasted I think was
it three days three days of rituals and
fasting and attention and maybe like
sleeplessness and whatever it is that
they did it like a whole huge like
ritual that lasted days and also lasted
a millennia in time
and so
if at the end of that
to like tip them over whatever they took
some kind of substance like now why the
hell is everybody just talking about
that substance now
now that's all people care about it's
like what's the formula what's the
chemical formula like what's the what's
the chemical
right because because exactly that like
we just we're just
that we we we're we're I mean we're
materialists and we're lit we think that
that's
that that's what Transcendence is it's
like you know and so I've seen so but
I'm not saying it's completely I've
never taken psychedelics right so uh but
I have met people that have taken
psychedelics and it transformed their
life for the better to be honest I admit
them I've also met psychedelic people
who've taken psychedelics and that it
turned them into psychos
like just turn them into complete cycles
and they lost their they lost their
family they lost their jobs they became
they've just lost it uh and so
like whatever psychedelics are if they
rip the veil away or whatever I think
that like you said
I think that the discipline of practice
whether it's prayer where whether it is
music whether it is uh you know dance
whether it's all these different things
is is far more integrated and far more
useful for your life than just having
like a tourist experience in the in the
Transcendent it's like here I am you
know some tourists walking and walking
through this world of spirits
I don't know just to me like it just
sounds very dangerous also because I
have met people that have just
completely lost their lives because of
the because of them
well thank you very much um Winnie did
you have a question yeah I did um I will
backtrack our conversation a little bit
so
um uh earlier when we were talking about
modernism and also when you were talking
about Innovation you sort of brought up
twice in different ways you you sort of
talked about this concept of having
something new whether it's caused by
extreme Visions or where it's caused by
um I like just fresh ideas
um and then sort of uh finding that is
more traditional and compatible with it
and then um sort of marrying those two
um as sort of the middle ground
um how do you identify what is
compatible with what is there some sort
of
identifiable law or pattern behind that
uh yeah I think there are
um
there are there are in the sense of
they are in the sense of the
practicality you know I think that's one
of the reasons why I talked about this
idea of like embodiment in a community
and so that is usually part of it it's a
I think the one of the I mean I
it's not easy because it's like the the
opportunities to create embodied works
of art right now are very are very you
know far in between it's not like
something that we that we can do it's
not like a lot of people get
commissioned to like write you know
a piece of music to celebrate the
anniversary of something or whatever
like it's it's difficult for that that
to happen but like usually that would
have been part of the the the meat of
the of the art right part of the the
consistency of it would have been its
integration into its purpose
so like what is its purpose so like
let's say I write a piece of music for a
dance
is not the same that if I write a piece
of music as a national anthem right if I
write a piece of music in a church
you know it's not the same as if I write
a lullaby for a child like those
actually
can are recognized by people as
participating in their world so it's
like it's not a it's there's a part of
it which is objective which I think has
an objective pattern and so it's like
lullabies usually aren't fast and fast
tempo they they're slow and you know
they have a kind of a way to to modulate
sound that that is appropriate to the to
their to their use but then there's also
just the historical reality of what you
live in right the world in which you
live has certain traditions of of
sonority certain traditions of space
certain traditions of images that you
just kind of you just kind of continue
and you you you participate in now in
terms of an actual pattern
usually the pattern is is like uh you
know it you can understand it like a
wave you can understand it like uh like
a circumambulation right so you you
start at the center you move out and
then you return to the center not
exactly the center maybe another point
which is similar to it that tends to be
the pattern of pretty much everything
all stories tend to have that pattern
um
you know uh images have that pattern in
in space so they have a central focus
and then they'll have a an edge or a
margin and then that edge of margin has
characteristics and the central Focus
has characteristics
um and so that's the way that I would
see it in terms of music I it I don't
know like I said the technical aspect of
it enough but usually that's the way
that's the the pattern you can impress
it different ways it can be a mountain
like a coming up or coming down the
mountain it can be like I said it can
just be this like a like a serpent
moving around an axis so it's like a a
pattern that cycles and returns it
changes a bit and cycles and returns and
changes a bit
so a mix of recognizability and
difference
right so if you have enough of that like
I mean I think Bach is the best for that
like a few is fugue is like almost like
the perfect vision of that right it's
like he's he gives you something he
States it and then he's like let me play
with this and he plays and he plays and
at some point you're like where where is
this going I don't even know what's
going on anymore it's like oh and then
all of a sudden you're like wait a
minute no no I see it I see it it's here
it's coming it's coming and then all of
a sudden it comes not exactly maybe even
the way you wanted to and it's like
that's that's like probably in terms of
the way I would understand like in terms
of Music one of the best
versions of that pattern
just uh coincidentally next door
someone's playing the piano
um they're playing a mystical piece by
screaming
and it just made me think of um some
things we haven't wrote in his diary
because he was very interested in this
sort of um similar to you talk about
like the the Orthodox the theory this
idea of like sort of becoming sort of
united with god
um but squealand writes in his diary uh
I am God
um
this is this is something that I think
um could potentially be a problem with
this sort of new understanding of
religion as a sort of symbolic language
that people will try and like we were
talking earlier about like the modernist
like they try and create the music
instead of Discover it
um in this way with religion people are
sort of I worry that people will start
to create
um religions out of this sort of
symbolic
um
substrate
um do you think do you worry about the
same thing and how how do you how how do
you just on top of that like how do you
then defend a religious belief without
it being attached to something like a
Dogma yeah
um
I mean I see it happening it's happening
now it's happening all the time like the
religious is crashing back into our
world you know with speeds that are hard
to that are hard to deal with uh and
it's happening in ways that are very um
that are kind of chaotic and kind of
messy so you know we saw during covid
kovid was an acceleration like an
accelerant of religious patterns I mean
it was nuts in terms of watching you
know taboos get set up and then you know
scapegoating and then also George Floyd
during during the the the
um
during covet it was crazy it was like it
was a religious event I mean it was
circumambulation and and uh and like you
know kind of EX ecstatic Union after
fasting so think about it like people
had been like isolated in their houses
for months and then someone gets
sacrificed and then all of a sudden it's
like it's like it's always like
dionysian in terms of of what was going
on during George Floyd and so we're
seeing it happen all around and it's
it's kind of uh you know it's scattered
and it's messy and so I think that it's
that we are definitely in danger of
seeing because religious patterns
you know it's like religious patterns
are super dangerous like they're so
dangerous so like most Dogma like dogma
and rules and taboos like you know
thought out taboos and rituals are there
in some way to mediate the religious in
the world because it tends to burn like
a fire right if it comes through it's
not it it can leave you know if you if
you read the Baka the Baka you can see
what religious patterns do if people
kind of let themselves go to that
inebriation you know it leads to uh
asparagus right it leads to ripping a
part of the world
um and so I do think that we're
definitely in danger of seeing that um
happen and we have I think covet was
really an example where we could kind of
see a glimpse of what was possible in
terms of a religiosity in a in a secular
kind of uh technological World
um
and so I do think that I do think that
document Dogma is a is actually a good
thing to a certain extent like if Dogma
is if Dogma is
is understood in its proper place right
and so you know for example in Orthodox
Christianity we have
we have a Creed
we have a statement of faith we have
things that we believe and we also
understand that it's apophatic which is
that these are not positive statements
they are in some ways protective
statements or negative statements to
avoid us from becoming crazy but
ultimately the Transcendent is beyond
that so God is beyond like it's like
you know I can I could I'd say I believe
definitely believe in the Holy Trinity
but I could also say God is not a father
or a son or a spirit like that is not
heretical at all like because we know
that these are kind of negative
statements to help us understand so I do
I do think that Dogma in religion is is
inevitable and necessary because without
it it leads to like like new age
insanity
but it leads to it leads to like Crystal
like just you know Cults and and gurus
and like you know
like neo-tantric ins like Madness that
we've seen happen in the past you know
you know 10 20 years uh which leads to
really I mean it really destroys people
like I know people that have been
destroyed by new tantrism like really
like psychologically messed up so I
think a lot of the
so I do think that dog was important
because or else or else we're we're in
trouble so sorry I I hope we're not
disappointing you guys too much with
that
I come from a very religious
country from Sri Lanka and uh the
biggest religion is Buddhism and there
there's giantia and Islam
um but there was always a respect for
each other's religion but as I came to
England especially to University it
could be because I lived in such a
religious country I saw so many
um
forms of religion in University in the
secular form meaning or here's a belief
for example gender is a spectrum you
have to believe it if not you will be
you know it works in the old days of the
heretic and this there's a big it was on
the levels or you need oh I see even
there's this
kind of negative uh view on white male
as if the white male is the worst thing
to exist and all opportunities are given
based on
you know sex or based on color and not
anymore unmarried so I feel yes it
wasn't a conversation I wasn't expecting
coming to the west but in the west how
do you think we can have just more
conversation between uh different
beliefs and just more respect for
different beliefs
yeah it's hard I mean because the the
religion let's say the the the ascendant
religion you know right now uh
I would say there are different versions
but that the the woke kind of ascended
religion is definitely one like it's
definitely one it's it's part of it's
part of it because it has a it has a
kind of a Zeal right and right it has
that that that oh like fundamentalist
Zeal where you can't question there's
something you can't say like if you if
you if you ask even just ask questions
about certain things like there's a
there's a kind of you know fire Divine
fire that just like rushes out of people
and so I think I think we're definitely
in that in that world now
it's really a problem because
you know all religions will exclude like
all religions will have dark skeletons
in their closet but the the the way
religions are set up is not arbitrary
and so
they actually have there's a reason why
they're set up the way they are and so
for example if you take I mean I'm a
Christian so obviously I understand
Christianity better you know the the
notion of the the of of Christ for
example the notion of the crucifixion
right is in some ways a way to safeguard
against the things we're hap we're
seeing now which is that it's like I I
see myself as the one who crucified
Christ for example right I see myself
I see in the one that is beaten and
rejected and and refused I see in them
an image of God
um
and then I try not to to do that let's
say but now we have this it's like a
weird the the modern one it's like
almost like a weird parody of
Christianity where you know Christianity
has always had a deep compassion for
victims and a deep desire to love the
the oppressed and the marginalized but
now it's like we it's like being
weaponized where it's like let's flip it
upside down we're now
the marginalized in the oppressed you
know have the right to demand of the of
other people this have the right to
let's say exclude uh the the the the the
others and so we we're returning to more
of like an ancient
like religion and Purity like a almost
like a
like a yeah you know you know in the in
the uh in the Jew in the Jewish temple
for example in the Hebrew Temple you
know strangers weren't allowed in to the
temple at all like they weren't allowed
to come in and so it's like we're
returning to that type of of behavior so
um yeah hopefully
I mean we all hope that it'll just kind
of play it'll play out without too much
violence I guess is the because in some
ways it it can't I don't think it can
sustain itself that type of thinking at
on the long term
but uh yeah and it's a we're in a
strange situation that's for sure but
actually the solution I think though the
solution and this this has been the
solution that I've been pruning is to
help people understand the function of
the margin and the exception and the
strange and so you know I talk about
monsters a lot I talk about margins and
I talk about idiosyncrasy and it's like
you know or talk about Carnival in a lot
of my talks about with the function of
Carnival in the traditional Society so
it's I think that because what happens
is that the right or the the
conservatives or whatever the people
reacting to this woke thing I mean they
just go full on too and so so you just
create these two these two opposites
that just can't talk to each other it's
it's horrible uh and I think the best
way would be to help people to
understand the role of of the strange
but then also understand that it's
strange for a reason it's like
you know the margins are marginal
and the marginal has a function in the
world
and that function has positive and
negative aspects to it
and it's like if you want the positive
aspects of the margin you kind of have
to live with the negative aspects of the
margin if you want the positive aspects
of the center you have to live with the
negative aspects of them so you can't
have it all like you just can't you
can't be a margin and a tyrant at the
same time that doesn't that that leads
to Absolute Madness so we need we need
to find the I think the proper balance
so
um just as a Orthodox Christian you're
saying Dogma has its place do you think
then that right action or orthopraxy
requires Orthodoxy
I think so I mean I think they go
together for sure
um because you know the the especially
in Orthodoxy in other types of
Christianity maybe not so much like in
Orthodoxy it really is the Liturgy you
know and so
so for example like we sing the Creed
during liturgy we don't just abstractly
think it we sing it together
and so as we sing it together we're
manifesting our unity and so that's
actually moving us towards communion
that's why you know in the the the the
Creed for example it's place in the
Liturgy is moving now because there's
the first part of the Liturgy uh which
is which used to be for kind of
everybody and then there's the second
part of the Liturgy which used to be
just for the people that are baptized
and so the second part of the Liturgy is
like this like compression moving
towards the meal where we all share the
same you know the same uh sacred meal
and uh and I think that we have to
understand that the Orthodoxy and the
the orthopraxy they just they just go
like that because it's a celebration of
what we have in common
both in practice you know and in love of
one another but also in mind to a
certain extent and then kind of moving
towards the the communion childhood so
yeah I think you need both
um
um what is your opinion on the current
movement
of
uh
spirituality without religion do you
think those two things are separable
no I don't think I don't think they're
separable and the and the reason why is
you know we talked about this fractal
pattern you know we talked about how
these these the patterns of the world
they kind of exist at different scales
and one of the problems with the like
spiritual but not religious is that
the spiritual but not religious person
says
I don't want this spiritual pattern to
bind me to others I just want it to be
my own individual thing
and so the only way for it to bind you
to others is through common something
that's how you're bound to others you're
bound to others through common action
through common attention through common
singing through common movement and so
that's religion I don't know what to
tell you and so if we stand together if
we sing together if we if we process
together if we bow together if we do the
things that we do together then the
spiritual
is not just binding me as an individual
but it's binding me to my family and my
family to a larger communion etc etc
and so and so the the spiritual but not
religious is just another version of of
modernism
because it it doesn't like the fractal
relationship it wants to reduce to the
individual it's like I want to be I want
to be an individual in relationship to
the Transcendent complete transcendent
right and see that uh that extreme that
I mentioned it's like I want like the
absolute Transcendent like you know uh
non-being of Nirvana and I just wanted
me I don't want it to buy me to others
like I just want it to be me and so and
so I I don't think
I don't think I mean it's better like I
I'd prefer spiritual but not religious
to
I don't know to someone who goes dancing
at the club every day like you know it's
like I prefer someone who who who who
who has spiritual practice even if if
there's if they're idiosyncratic and
personal rather than someone who drinks
you know gin all night like it you know
it's like there's a hierarchy of things
but I do believe that
that that true spirituality will have
religion attached to it because it's a
it's a binding agent in a way it's the
the same answer as you you gave before
it it comes from Pride isn't it uh
spiritual religion in a way is like
wanting to keep the meaning without
accepting the truth
and without having to submit to
Authority a lot of it's that too it's
like well I don't want to submit to any
Authority I just want to have my own
experiences and you know it's like I
want to have my my own thing
but that's just not how the world works
you know what happens actually it's and
I know it sounds weird it's like what
happens is the opposite it's like you're
gonna end up submitting to authorities
that have never existed before we're
going to end up submitting to levels of
authority that have never existed in the
history of the world like we're moving
towards
like weird authoritarian systems that
are
that are going to be total
and it's like it goes together like the
extreme you know I always say it's like
a punk rocker can only exist in in a
world that is ex completely buffered and
completely controlled and completely
maintained on a schedule
because if you put a punk rocker in the
Amazonian jungle like they'll die in one
day two days because they're not bound
like so you need these extreme systems
of like control and so if you if you if
you try to move towards idiosyncrasy and
you're like I just want me my spiritual
thing my own thing like I'm just gonna
take a hodgepodge do whatever I want
it's like you're creating that Rift
and what's gonna and it's it's actually
it's going up too it's gonna it's gonna
create
yeah systems of control
I know it sounds weird it sounds like
it's a contradiction but if you look if
you think about modernism that way it
actually will solve a lot of problems
for why modernism happened the way it
did
because that's what it looks like
is necessary
relationship with the Transcendent how
and do we avoid the Dark Side of Dogma
I mean
Saints I don't know what to tell you
it's like I mean you need developing
your own life instead of focusing on
others like I think that's probably the
best it's like it's like loving others
and then you know seeing sin in myself I
mean that's for sure like I'm talking
way more from a Christian perspective
I'm sorry but it's like I think that
from a Christian perspective
uh you know there's a joke about how
there's a joke about how you know
Protestants think that you know no one's
going to heaven except for me right or
except for my game and there's a joke in
Orthodoxy which is that everybody's
going to heaven except me
that's that's probably the best approach
right is to see your own sin and to to
to to to to always focus on your own on
your own lack and then and then and then
you probably will be able to avoid the
problems of Dogma if you do that right
can I just uh sorry
it just like with the last thing you
just said then so then how do you avoid
the psychological problems with that
what do you mean just
I guess the association like everyone is
going about
it's mostly a mental immense state where
you're just trying to not see yourself
as higher than others you know and so we
we obviously you also yeah
you wouldn't if in that state you're
self-flagellating then that's Pride too
by the way it's like self-flagellation
is pride you know most people that are
like
because you think you think you're so
important Frank you think you're that
important that you should flog yourself
uh but I think that just the this this
sense of like attending to your own
thoughts and attending to your own uh
and not thinking that you should be
better than you are because a lot of the
psychological problems that we have is
that we think that we should be better
than we are so it's not that it's not
that that it's not that we actually
think we're wretched is that is that we
think we're wretched but we think we
should be awesome like we should be
heroes but we notice we're actually
wretched uh I think that that's the
problem but it but if you just kind of
see your own sins and you're like okay I
mean from a Christian perspective you
just see your own sin you're like yeah
you know just give it up like I don't
know like when we confess our sins in
Orthodoxy we confess our sins like it's
like we're sinning constantly so we
always say for all the sins all the sins
you know that known and unknown like all
my I don't even know that I'm sinning
like I'm just sinning all the time and
so if you're in that state where it's
like you actually think that you're just
sinning constantly so much that you
don't even know how much you're sinning
it's like and you know it's like are you
is there even room to sell flashlights
you know it's like you just that's how
it's how it is and so all you do is you
kind of just give up and you just you
know
yeah so I hope that I hope that but it's
like by the way I don't do that because
I'm not a saint I've got a lot of Pride
don't worry like I'm not I hope you know
I'm a hypocrite like that's for sure I
just hope that's clear thank you
oh no it was I guess it's a question to
both of you because you seem to be in
agreement uh you you were saying you
were talking about the problems of Dogma
or the Dark Side of dogma and I wonder
if you could elaborate on what this is
no but the Dark Side of Dark Minds that
he gives you an insight to judge other
people that's what it is it's like it's
like as soon as you you you have
something which binds you and it's not
just Dogma it's the problem of any Unity
so as soon as you have something that
binds you
together as soon as you have any group
anything that you see in that you see
that you have in common with others and
binds you that immediately creates an
outside
there's no way around it you can't you
can't have it all right it's like I know
that a lot of the like weird post-modern
moves to just try to integrate
everything into everything but that
doesn't work it destroys the world so so
so you could say
so you could see it in in all kinds of
things right if you think of a sports
team right you you if a sports team will
have things that bind them together and
then they will have adversaries that are
outside them that they're fighting and
so that's part of any type of unity now
the problem with religion is that it
does that too it does it in the absolute
because it's like I have
I have access to God through this and so
now it gives me Ultimate Weapon to like
to judge other people if I if I let
myself go to that so that's the danger
of Dogma uh and I think I mean I do
think that
I think that we have the tools
you know I know for I think for sure
within Christianity we have the tools to
fight that and I think part of the
nature of Christianity is is to avoid
that problem in in the image of Christ
himself in The Sermon on the Mount and
all these these aspects but that's
definitely an issue and you know if
you'll catch yourself doing it all the
time
thank you
so I think it's come up a lot tonight
that pride is kind of sort of behind a
lot of the sources of many problems
exactly so what's so what's your
antidote to Pride
I mean I think I just formulated it
right I think it's it's to to try to see
your own lacks first right to try to see
what what you're missing yourself and so
practicing humility in the sense that
you know if you see
like a an easy an easy trick to do and
it's like when I'm in my best moments I
can do this but it's not often but like
usually you catch yourself thinking
something right you know you know you
look at someone and you catch yourself
kind of judging them or you know
whatever or even if you're in
relationship you can't just you know you
judge your your partner uh and I think
it's like the discipline of right away
asking yourself
like could I say the same thing about me
right and so it's like you know someone
lies and you're like yeah they're lying
it's like yeah do I lie yeah okay yeah
okay so it's like I'm not saying that
this that say the thing that's happening
to me or the stuff let's say someone's
doing something to you it's like it
doesn't justify it it doesn't mean
you'll justify it but it's like it's
like if I've been crappy to others right
you know if I lost my temper if I so
it's like so just kind of remembering
yourself in a way so that so that you so
then it what it does is it kind of
mediates I think the issue now I'm not
saying you should
it doesn't mean you should accept
everything I don't think so unless
you're really like a monk or something
but it I think that it just the
discipline of always asking yourself
what aspect of what bothers me because
often the worst part of it is that
sometimes when something bothers you
with someone it's usually because you've
got a little seat of that yourself right
and so it's like oh that person's really
cocky it's like really why are you
noticing that you know
like you might have a little bit of that
yourself and that's why you're noticing
it uh and so yeah so I I would say that
that's probably the best the best way
to go about that
I think Jonathan gave a solution here
early as well as he was talking about
sitting and catching yourself sitting
all the time and then you know when you
see your
you know sitting all the time just kind
of give up and that's also surrendering
to your higher power is also a big
advantages
not quite making sense to me is that
this at the end of the day still sounds
psychologically detrimental because it's
still referrals like self-referential um
like in in all the examples that you
have given so maybe I could maybe I
could I could uh I could take the same
thing that I said but now flip it the up
the other way which is that what if what
if every time you you come in the
morning and then there's someone who's
impatient or there's someone who's
annoying or whatever then maybe try to
notice something about them that that
that is positive do it that way do it do
it the other way if you don't like the
like the seed on yourself like just try
to remember that that person is a human
being that has a life and experiences
and that you know that that so if it's
hard for you to say to see how you're
the same in terms of the negative part
you can maybe rather try to see the
mirror
no the mirror of the good in the other
person
um
I mean there's I'm not saying that it's
it's always possible but but I would say
that that might be uh uh
yeah a better maybe another way to do
something similar that would be also
kind of humility
just one thing that uh Peter graved I'm
sure you do maybe you've talked to him
personally I don't know uh but Peter
Graves really uh showed in an interview
or a book I don't remember
humility is
an arrow that points outwards whereas
pride is an arrow that points inwards
and so I think it's in this sense that
the over judging ourselves and over
criticizing in this posture of I'm so
bad I'm it's really me me me me yeah so
put it very simply
humility is whatever
points outwards and yeah this one
[Music]
I remember hearing the Dalai Lama
actually say that someone asked him
about about
um people who are are shy
and he said it's Pride
it's like it's fried because you're too
self-conscious you're thinking about
yourself way too much I do it's like you
think you're so important that people
are looking at you like you think people
are like concerned with you and your
presentation and all these things and
like that's what makes you shy it's
interesting I mean I don't know if it's
if it's it's completely true but I just
thought it interesting that he totally
like switched it in terms of the way we
think of it now
um
yeah
I mentioned that because like when you
meant when you mentioned the prize and
then answered those and initiative
facility isn't there reminded me of uh
there's a cartoon called The Avatar of
The Last Airbender and there was a quote
in there like with a high roll basically
saying uh and paraphrasing
um pride is not the opposite of shame
but it Source uh the only
true humility is the only antidote to
break
yeah I think something could be on
YouTube for that as well because true
beauty is always taking you out of
yourself isn't it and and what you are
saying earlier about organism is that is
Inward and not pointing to something
outward
yeah yeah well there's a definitely an
aspect of of modernism that's like a
kind of radical yeah
you know a radical subjectivity you know
and so it's like you go to a museum and
some artist has their whole thing like
they just have you know they probably
wrote books and books about the thing
they're doing and then you walk up to it
and it's just I don't know it's like
strands of hair hanging from the ceiling
right and and it's like and it's like
yeah this person spent like 20 years
working on this project and it's like
and then it's like why so really I
should care like I should care enough
about your little idiosyncratic world to
like dive in and like discover all the
references that you're like I'm sorry I
just don't have the energy for it and
also like really are you gonna subject
me to that like your own little like
your own little idiosyncratic world
I don't know I'm not interested
it points outwards like to me that
sounds a lot like compassion right in a
sense like everything should sort of
yeah there you go it's good
um and and
for us as musicians then do you think
that how how do we I guess be
compassionate performance are we in
service to our audiences is that
compassion
I would hope so I mean
I think that you have to be careful like
when you say service your audience of
course you
there's like a there's a balance I think
there's a balance because also you're
trying to like let's say
you you make a piece of art so on the
one hand you are trying to to let's say
reach out to have compassion for your
audience but there's also a way in which
you're also trying to kind of take them
by the hand and and kind of pull them
into something there's so there's a
there is both there's like both you know
you you can find I think a nice middle
ground because it you know I think that
modern pop composition is like it's like
it's like the worst of trying to please
the audience
because they're just like you know what
can I get people to click on and then
you know it's it's just like things
songs appear and then vanish you know
within within a few months but it has to
do with that problem of like trying to
like really hit what people want right
now you know and just kind of give them
what they want uh but I think that that
true art is not that is not like that
like there's a there's a
yeah there's a balance between let's say
kind of teasing how can I say this
it's all it's I mean you think of think
about it really like a meal right it's
like so I I'm I I will I'm offering
something of sustenance to the person
but then I will have Spice in it in
order to make it attractive and make it
taste good but there also has to be
like substance to it you know
so so element of you inputting part of
yourself
um is
well that's going to happen inevitably I
tend to think people shouldn't put too
much effort into that like I mean that's
like the opposite of of contemporary
thinking it's mostly in service of
something I hope like in service of
something higher
right in service of some so it's like
for example if you if you say I mean I'm
just thinking out loud here because I
it's difficult for music now like I said
to but if you let's say like I want to
bring I want to
bring joy to people like I want or I
want to I want people to experience
longing like I want that them to kind of
move into that experience of longing and
have a sense of that and so it's like
you're serving a higher purpose you're
like trying to you're basically like
training people to have these
experiences and these subtle experiences
um and so and so you want to do it in a
way that they'll recognize what you're
doing that they're seeing that that
you're they see the breadcrumbs right or
they can get the little breadcrumbs as
they're moving into what you're doing
and then once they're there then you can
kind of take them on a trip I just want
you to know I need I have a meeting at
three so I have like about you know yeah
I just wanted to say just on top of what
we were just talking about which is such
a beautiful
part of the conversation it echoed very
closely what we were talking about with
John viveki which was this idea that
love is the opposite of addiction and so
I was this idea of Pride being something
that's Inward and humility but using
this outward John viveki was saying that
addiction
um is something that is reciprocally
narrowing and narrowing it sort of like
thing where your framing comes
increasingly closer and closer but the
opposite of that is reciprocal opening
um and he calls that what love is and I
think that's a beautiful line of
agreement with with you and and John
yeah definitely I think for on that case
we really agree I I really recently I've
been using Dante a lot as an image of
that and I think that for art it's
probably a good image to understand
let's say what Dante was trying to do in
the Comedia
which is exactly that would it has to do
with your question about so you could
understand that
let's say I I make a piece of art and I
do it in service of a higher good right
you know in the celebration of God the
celebration of of Love or the
celebration of something beautiful
beautiful
um
but then I understand that like that
people don't have access to that and so
what I do is I engage lower lungs
right in order to draw people in to this
higher this higher celebration and so
you know so then you can use let's say
you can almost like seduce people into
the experience so you use tropes that
people recognize or you surprise them or
you do different things but their
purpose is actually just to draw them up
into something something more and you
see in Dante you see that because it's
something like he starts with poetry
right he starts with Virgil it's like
Virgil is that's that lower love these
structure these artistic patterns that
we use in order to create our work right
that's what Virgil is that's what Virgil
represents and so it's like the craft
the the you know the techniques all
these things that we have there's
nothing wrong with them
you know especially we have to think
about that especially in the modern
world because people have seen these
techniques and these this craft as being
factitious as being like tricks and
things that you shouldn't use because
you know they're cliche or whatever but
if they're in service of a higher good
then all of a sudden they find their
purpose and so you you you can use these
these techniques in order to draw people
into higher loves and so you know Dante
moves from Virgil to Beatrice which is a
woman that that a lot that awoke love in
him when he was a young person then he
moves up towards uh towards Saints
ultimately towards towards God himself
and so it's like these embedded loves
it's a good way to understand it but you
can also understand that in in art which
is that this is because I I remember a
friend of mine who's a contemporary
painter that I love very much at some
point he
he was basically saying like why are you
doing this like the icon thing like why
are you doing this stuff it's all it's
all done it's all been done right it's
all these these these tricks and and
tropes and images that have all been
done and it's like
I can do it because I'm I'm making an
image for someone's baptism
but I can do it because I'm making an
image to go into a church
like I have a reason
that that's an actual reason like that
this object will enter into a community
will participate in the life of it of a
church of a family or whatever and so
and so the lower loves these lower
aspects these techniques the the the the
way the lines work or the way you know
using a Halo and all these things are in
service of a higher participation and so
there's no shame in using them right I'm
not
um I'm not pretending that they are that
they are uh
that they are new or Innovative or
whatever it doesn't matter
beautiful I think that would be a really
lovely place to end and especially
because you've got something coming up
but thank you so much it's been an
amazing chat
thank you
[Applause]